bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de descartes
pourquoi des cartes déjà parce que des
cartes c'est un peu un incontournable de
la philosophie française
c'est difficile de passer à côté c'est
vraiment le genre de philosophes qui a
apporté quelque chose à la manière de
penser il a été très influent sur son
époque sur la pensée européenne en
général et donc parler de philosophie
sans évoquer des cartes
c'est un petit peu compliqué alors des
cartes
si je devais le définir pour introduire
cette présentation
je dirais que c'est d'abord un obsédé de
la vérité évidemment c'est une formule
un peu réductrice parce que on peut pas
résumer des cartes simplement à ce trait
de sa démarche
mais c'est quand même un aspect très
important de la démarche cartésienne
l'obsession de la vérité alors qu'est ce
que j'appelle l'obsession de la vérité
tous les philosophes ont l'obsession la
vérité d'une certaine manière c'est
derrière ça le principe le philosophe
c'est celui qui cherche cette vérité qui
veulent atteindre à tout prix sauf que
chez descartes ça va prendre une forme
assez radical c'est à dire que des
cartes effrayé qu'il est de se tromper
d'être dans l'erreur d'être dans le faux
va aller jusqu'à remettre en doute tout
ce qu'il croit savoir et selon lui ça
c'est la base de la démarche
philosophique à savoir de mettre en
doute de mettre en question tout ce que
l'on croît être vrai donc nos croyances
nos préjugés nos impressions
alors faut savoir que des cartes c'était
un philosophe mais c'était aussi un
scientifique c'était un mathématicien
est un physicien donc c'est quelqu'un
qui ne séparait pas la philosophie du
champ de la recherche en général
et d'ailleurs cette séparation entre la
philosophie et les sciences
elle s'est vraiment affirmé au 19e
siècle parce que jusqu'à vent on
concilier très bien la philosophie avec
les sciences ou en tout cas on ne les
mettait pas en rivalité ou en
concurrence donc des cartes
fort de sa méthode scientifique
va décider de l'appliquer au chant de la
vérité aux champs de la connaissance
philosophique est ce qu'il va remarquer
c'est que nous sommes tous remplis
d'idées fausses ces idées fausses
on en n'est pas totalement responsable
ce n'est pas simplement la marque d'une
ignorance naturel lit d'une bêtise de
l'homme non c'est vraiment tout un tas
de facteurs qui s'additionnent et qui
font que nous tombons régulièrement dans
l'erreur alors il va donner quelques
exemples
il va parler de l'enseignement de
l'éducation qu'on a reçue de
l'instruction donc des cartes va
mentionné le fait qu'il peut arriver dès
fois que nous apprenions des choses qui
ne sont pas totalement conformes à la
réalité
et vous savez très bien parce que vous
êtes allé à l'école tout comme moi peut
depuis l'époque où vous alliez à l'école
il y a des choses qui ont été revisités
il ya des choses qui ont été corrigés
dans ce qu'on pouvait apprendre ça
concerne évidemment tout le champ de
l'histoire évidemment parce que l'
histoire est une science en évolution
perpétuelle en réécriture perpétuelle
mais même dans le domaine des sciences
il ya des choses qui étaient considérés
comme valables il ya encore vingt ou
trente ans qu'ils ne sont plus
aujourd'hui donc les manuels scolaires
évolué et c'est vrai qu'on peut parfois
apprendre des choses durant notre
enfance qui se révéleront fausse par la
suite alors il n'y a pas que l'éducation
que des cartes met en accusation
il y a aussi ce que des cartes appelle
l'opinion et l'opinion c'est un petit
peu l'idée de tout le monde l'idée qui
n'a pas réellement de fondement ou de
justification
donc c'est vraiment le degré 1 de la
connaissance l'opinion c'est un savoir
qui n'en est pas un en réalité donc
c'est quelque chose vis-à-vis de quoi il
faut entretenir beaucoup de méfiance et
ça signifie concrètement qu'il ne faut
pas se fier à ce que l'on va nous dire
il ne faut pas tout prendre pour argent
comptant il ne faut pas accepter les
informations sans les vérifier au
préalable
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là c'est à dire
que outre l'éducation outre l'opinion
des cartes va jusqu'à dire que c'est
notre constitution même en tant qu'être
humain qui nous porte à faire des
erreurs qui nous porte à faire des
erreurs qui nous prédisposent en quelque
sorte à nous tromper
et l'exemple que donne des cartes c'est
l'exemple de nos sens nos cinq sens ce
que montre des cartes c'est que il
arrive fréquemment que nos sens nous
induisent en erreur c'est à dire que on
va voir des choses on va sentir des
choses on va entendre des choses et on
va se tromper sur leur nature sur leur
origine
on va être soumis à des illusions donc
les plus connus sont évidemment les
illusions d'optique
le fait de voir quelque chose qui
n'existe pas réellement qui n'est pas là
devant nous on peut aussi parler des
illusions auditive comme par exemple
quand on a l'impression d'entendre notre
prénom crier dans la rue alors qu'en
fait non c'était juste une onomatopée
qui ressemblait vaguement donc les
illusions sensorielle on en a tous fait
l'expérience et on sait qu'il est donc
possible parfois de se tromper d'avoir
une perception biaisée une perception
altérée de la réalité et que donc on ne
peut pas totalement intégralement se
fier à nos sens dans une démarche de
connaissance donc déjà le point de
départ de descartes c'est quand même le
constat de tous les obstacles à la
connaissance des cartes vraiment insiste
beaucoup là-dessus d'ailleurs je vous
invite vraiment à lire son livre le
discours de la méthode parce que c'est
dans ce livre là que des cartes expose
sa méthode de la manière la plus claire
de la manière vraiment la plus
compréhensible pour tous et donc dans ce
livre d'écart décide de nous raconter
son cheminement c'est à dire que ça
prend presque des allures
autobiographique et des cartes l'on
raconte voilà son enfance ses années
d'enseignement ses années d'études et il
accumule les éléments qui montrent que
la connaissance est quelque chose de
fragile de précaires qui est basée sur
de nombreuses croyances fausses ou sur
de nombreuses opinions de nombreux
préjugés
donc c'est vraiment ça qui anime la
démarche de les cartes c'est à dire de
pointe et tout ce qui va à un moment ou
à un autre nous posait problème dans
l'accès à la connaissance et la grande
difficulté pour les êtres humains que
nous sommes c'est que nous n'avons accès
au monde que par l'intermédiaire de nos
sens or nos sens sont douteux nos sens
ne sont pas fiables
on doit se méfier de ce que nous disent
nos sens alors l'un des exemples que je
donne souvent pour illustrer ça à mes
élèves c'est
l'exemple du bâton on va plonger dans un
cours d'eau et des cartes nous dit que
si on fait ça et qu'on regarde au niveau
de la surface de l'eau on aura
l'impression que le bâton et couper
qu'il est séparé de lui même en quelque
sorte ce qui n'est pas possible et
d'ailleurs il suffit de retirer le bâton
de l'eau pour s'apercevoir qu'à aucun
moment il n'a été coupé pourtant nous
l'avons vu couper parce que nous avons à
ce moment là étaient les victimes d'une
illusion d'optique qui nous a fait voir
la réalité autrement que ce qu'elle
n'est vraiment et bien des cas elle va
partir de ce genre d'exemple va partir
de ça pour en conclure qu'il ne faut
jamais faire confiance à nos sens et
qu'il ne faut jamais faire confiance à
nos opinions donc la démarche de
descartes c'est une démarche de méfiance
radical à l'égard de tout ce qui peut
être une source d'erreurs non pas à ce
qui a été démontré comme étant une
erreur mais à tout ce qui peut l'être
et qu'est-ce qui peut être
potentiellement faut bien des cartes
dira que tout peut être potentiellement
faut tout ce qui n'a pas été vérifié
tout ce qui n'a pas été démontrée ne
peut pas être tenu pour vrai et si on ne
peut pas à tenir quelque chose pour vrai
on doit la tenir pour potentiellement
fausses ce qui veut dire que des cartes
va partir du constat que toutes nos
connaissances étant marquée du sceau de
la fragilité
on doit suspendre toutes nos croyances
toutes nos connaissances toutes nos
opinions
le temps de reconstruire la connaissance
sur des bases solides
donc cette démarche on l'appelle souvent
la méthode du doute méthodique mais
aussi du doute radical ou encore
hyperbolique
alors pourquoi hyperbolique parce que
évidemment c'est une exagération de la
part de descartes à aucun moment des
cartes ne pense réellement que tout ce
que nous pensons peut être faux à aucun
moment ils ne l'envisagent sérieusement
et d'ailleurs il dit lui-même que le
temps de reconstruire notre connaissance
sur des bases solides
il faut fonctionner forcément avec nos
anciennes croyances on est obligé de
faire avec
on ne va pas tout à coup se retirer du
monde et ne jamais se positionner
donc il va conserver ce qu'on appelle la
morale par provision c'est à dire la
morale qu'on conserve provisoirement le
temps de vérifier si elle était fondée
ou pas si elle était juste
si fier ou pas donc des cartes va se
mettre à douter il va douter de ce qu'il
voit il va douter de ce qu'il entend il
va douter de ce qu'il croit savoir et il
va aller jusqu'à douter de lui-même ce
que veut dire des cartes c'est que si
mes sens sont douteux c'est à dire si je
dois me méfier d'eux s'il est possible
s'il ya la moindre chance qu'il puisse
me tromper ça veut dire que je ne peux
pas être absolument certain de mon
existence
en tout cas de mon existence corporelle
parce que mon existence corporelle j'en
ai la connaissance que par
l'intermédiaire de naissance c'est à
dire que je peux me voir je peux me
sentir je peux m'entendre mais tout ça
reste de l'ordre de l'expérience
sensorielle et comme l'expérience
sensorielle et douteuse définitivement
douteuses je ne peux pas m'appuyer sur
elle pour déduire mon existence donc des
cartes va postuler que je ne peux pas
affirmer que j'existe je dois douter de
mon existence comme je dois douter de
tout ce qui provient de mes sens de tout
ce qui provient de la croyance ou des
opinions de tous ceux dont je ne peux
pas avoir une certitude absolue une
certitude qui s'appuie sur une
vérification intégral sur une
démonstration absolue donc des cartes
c'est un peu la philosophie de la
paranoïa c'est partir du principe que
parce qu'une erreur est possible même si
c'est un pourcentage ridiculement faible
et bien le risque existe et si le risque
existe on prend pas ce risque
on pourrait dire que des cartes c'est
celui qui a douté pour être sûr parce
que en doutant de tous il est sûr de ne
jamais faire d'erreur il est sûr de ne
jamais se faire abuser
donc c'est assez ironique finalement de
se dire que c'est peut-être le
philosophe qui a le plus attaché de
valeur est d'importance à la notion de
vérité ou en tout cas une ambition
affichée d'atteindre cette vérité c'est
ironique qui soit arrivée à la vérité
grâce au doute parce que pour des cartes
le doute n'est qu'un outil le but de
descartes ce n'était pas de doute et
pour douter le doute n'est qu'un
instrument au service d'une méthode
c'est vraiment constitutifs d'une
méthode qui est d'écarter tout risque
d'erreur donc le doute va vraiment
apparaître comme un outil très précieux
pour accéder à la vérité
car au bout du raisonnement de descartes
il y à l'idée que si je peux douter de
tout il y a une chose dont je ne peux
pas douter il ya une chose qui va
résister à mon doute et c'est pas pour
rien que cette chose bien c'est le doute
lui même ce que veut dire des cartes
c'est que si je peux douter de tout
c'est bien la preuve que mon doute
existe alors le doute c'est pas quelque
chose de matériel c'est pas physique le
doute c'est pas comparable à un objet
corporelle
donc on parle évidemment d'existence
immatériel c'est comme dire par exemple
que une pensée existe non pas au sens où
elle serait constituée de molécules mais
au sens abstrait au sens impalpable
donc si je doute mon doute existe et qu
est ce que le doute il ya des cas qu'on
dit que le doute c'est une forme de la
pensée et donc la pensée c'est pas
quelque chose dont je peux avoir
l'illusion
c'est à dire que autant on peut avoir
une illusion d'optique et voir quelque
chose qui n'existe pas vraiment autant
quand on a une pensée dans la tête
cette pensée pourrait bien être une
illusion qu'elle resterait une pensée
parce que l'illusion de la pensée c'est
déjà de la pensée de la même façon que
quand on rêve
ce qu'on vit n'est pas réel mais le rêve
existe en tant que rêve
il existe en tant qu illusion il existe
en tant que penser donc c'est ça que
veut dire des cartes c'est que le doute
et donc par extension la pensée c'est
quelque chose dont je ne peux pas douter
c'est quelque chose dont je dois
constater l'existence et pour des cartes
ça prend vraiment la forme d'une
évidence d'une évidence absolue c'est à
dire que par quelques bouts comprennent
le problème on arrivera toujours à cette
conclusion la pensée existe donc là pour
des cartes on atteint vraiment une
première vérité c'est à dire que là où
notre expérience sensorielle va
finalement se heurter à un mur c'est à
dire qu'on ne va pas pouvoir franchir le
mur du doutons puisqu'on peut toujours
douter de nos perceptions peut toujours
douter de notre expérience
en revanche on ne peut pas douter de la
pensée on ne peut pas douter de
l'existence de la pensée ce qui veut
dire pour des cartes que si on doit
accepter que la pensée existe on doit
accepter que nous même qui pensent on
existe
ton et c'est ça qui va donner lieu à la
célèbre phrase de descartes je pense
donc je suis c'est à dire si ma pensée
existe il faut bien que j'existe pour
avoir cette pensée alors à vrai dire je
suis pas totalement d'accord avec cette
idée parce que l'idée du jeu dans la
phrase je pense est une idée qui elle
n'est pas forcément logique c'est à dire
je m'explique que le pronom je sais déjà
un parti-pris linguistique le pronom jeu
par exemple n'existe pas dans toutes les
langues
l'expression de l'individualité n'existe
pas dans toutes les langues
c'est déjà un parti-pris culturelle
linguistique et donc au final
anthropologique et philosophique dire je
pense ça n'a rien d'évident et même d'un
point de vue logique on pourrait presque
le contesté parce que la pensée est en
quelque chose d'immatériel c'est aussi
quelque chose d'un forme c'est quelque
chose qui n'a pas de contours qui n'a
pas de limite au sens spatiale du terme
et donc identifier la pensée à un
individu ou en tout cas à confondre les
deux c'est à dire considérer que la
pensée a forcément besoin de s'incarner
dans un individu physique c'est déjà
quelque chose qu'on pourrait contester
d'ailleurs c'est ce que disait nietzsche
il disait que nous n'avions pas d'idée
ce sont les idées qui viennent à nous et
quand on a une idée en fait on fait le
constat on fait l'observation d'une idée
qui vient de s'introduire en nous et
donc on peut finalement se dire que la
pensée n'est pas forcément le gage de
l'existence de l'individu
donc il est des cartes c'est vraiment
est définitivement d'imposer à l'esprit
l'évidence de notre existence à travers
la pensée c'est de dire que la pensée
donc l'esprit au delà de la pensée
individuelle
l'esprit est réellement la seule chose
dont on peut attester de l'existence
c'est vraiment la seule chose sur
laquelle on peut pas avoir de doutes
quant à l'existence
donc c'est quand même intéressant de
remarquer avec des cartes que la
première brique de l'édifice que doit
être la vérité cette brique élémentaire
elle renvoie quelque chose qui pour nous
dans notre vie quotidienne ne nous
paraît pas réel au sens où quand on
parle de la réalité on a plutôt tendance
à se référer à la matière aux corps et
aux objets donc se dire que la première
chose dont on va prouver l'existence
c'est quelque chose d'immatériel et
qu'on va construire toute notre
reconnaissance à partir de cette vérité
immatériel c'est quand même quelque
chose d'assez paradoxal
toujours est il que des cartes après
avoir découvert cette vérité première
c'est comme ça que qu'on la nomme la
vérité première c'est à dire la vérité
mère de toutes les autres vérités c'est
la vérité de notre existence de notre
existence en tant qu'individu notre
existence en tant qu'être pensant alors
là on touche à quelque chose qui me
paraît assez important parce qu'on
touche en fait à la manière dont des
cartes à influencer sa postérité pour
certains des cartes reste est un penseur
chrétien et c'est vrai que des cartes
était un philosophe chrétien c'est un
philosophe qui a tenté de prouver
l'existence de dieu
mais pour autant ce n'est pas quelqu'un
qui a fait de dieu un concept premier le
concept premier de descartes c'est le
doute et les concept dérivé de ce
concept de doute ce sont les concepts de
penser d'existence et d'individus donc
ce qui veut dire que d'un point de vue
purement religieux d'un point de vue
purement chrétiens des cartes est déjà
presque coupable d'une hérésie
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre que
jusqu'à la fin du moyen-âge
c'est à dire très peu de temps
finalement avant d'écarter toute la
philosophie était basé sur une idée
centrale et première qui était dieu
donc certes des cartes n'est peut-être
pas révolutionnaire de la laïcité au
xviie siècle mais c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui a osé commencer un traité
de philosophie en ne partant pas de dieu
mais en partant de l'individu
donc je veux dire c'est quand même pas
mal pour l'époque faut savoir que des
cartes en tant que scientifique
il était favorable aux thèses de
copernic et c'est quand il a appris que
galilée avait eu des ennuis à
avec son système héliocentrique que
descartes a renoncé à publier un ouvrage
qui justement aller dans le sens de
copernic
parce qu'il savait que c'était se tirer
une balle dans le pied que c'était se
condamner à la censure et donc à la
possibilité de délivrer sa parole
donc des cartes étaient tout sauf une
sorte de philosophe inquisiteur n'était
absolument pas un philosophe qui allait
jeter l'opprobre sur une pensée non
conformes aux dogmes va donc j'en
termine pour cette question de l'
influence de descartes et je
souhaiterais revenir sur une notion très
importante qu'on a esquissé mais selon
moi mérite vraiment qu'on l'approfondît
parce qu'elle permet de comprendre
beaucoup de choses
ce qu'on a vu c'est que des cartes
considère que la pensée est quelque
chose qui possède un degré de réalité
finalement beaucoup plus élevé que les
core c'est à dire que tout ce qui est de
l'ordre de la matière tout ce qui est
objet physique et ça évidemment on peut
pas s'empêcher de le mettre en relation
avec la vision qu'avaient platon et qui
disait que notre monde matériel n'était
qu'une projection d'un monde qui est le
monde des idées c'est à dire la
projection d'archétypes les archétypes
chez platon on les appelle les
archétypes on les appelle également les
idées ou les essences c'est très
difficile à définir et évidemment on
peut difficilement expliquer ce que sont
les archétypes sont passés par les
analogies
mais en tout cas c'est l'idée que notre
monde avant d'exister sous une forme
physique
il existe en tant qu'idée il existe en
tant que principe un petit peu si vous
voulez de la même façon que la loi de la
gravité préexiste à la gravité ce que je
veux dire c'est que la gravité n'est ce
qu'elle est qu'en vertu d'une loi qui la
gouvernent et bien cette loi qui la
gouvernent on pourrait dire que c'est un
petit peu l'archétype de la gravité et
la gravité ce serait la manifestation
dans le monde physique de cette idée de
gravité est donc le parallèle avec
platon se situe non seulement ici c'est
à dire dans cette idée d'une réalité au
delà du monde matériel
donc la réalité intelligent
bhl le monde des idées chez platon et
bien chez descartes ça prend la forme
d'une substance ce qu'il appelle une
substance et qui est la pensée
donc c'est des cartes quand on parle de
substances on parle pas forcément d'une
substance physique
donc là encore c'est difficile pour nous
de se représenter cette idée de
substances sans en faire quelque chose
de matériel
mais pour des cas c'est quelque chose
qui a autant de réalités en fait que la
substance physique c'est à dire que la
matière est ce que dire des cartes c'est
qu'il ne faut pas réduire la notion de
réalité à la réalité matérielle
parce que ce qu'on appelle la réalité
c'est ce qui est et ce qui est n'est pas
forcément d'ordre physique
donc là on retrouve le dualisme qu'on
trouvait déjà chez platon le dualisme
entre eux le monde sensible le monde
intelligible c'est à dire entre le monde
matériel et le monde de l'esprit et s'en
retrouve notamment dans un petit exemple
que donne des cartes
c'est le fameux exemple du morceau de
cire l'exemple du morceau de cire que
des cartes utilisent pour montrer que
tout ce qui existe dans le monde
physique est soumis à la corruption est
soumis à la transformation à l'évolution
est donc si on veut définir un objet
physique si on veut le définir dans ce
qui le constitue au plus profond de
lui-même au niveau de son essence
et bien tout ce qu'on va pouvoir dire
sur le morceau de cire pour le définir
n'est en aucun cas liée à ses
caractéristiques physiques
donc ça décape ou le raconte
concrètement il nous dit je prends un
morceau de cire il est petit il est
plutôt dur il est blanc je vais
l'approché du feu et là je vais le voir
se transformer il va devenir liquide il
va devenir plus foncée il va fondre se
répandre et donc au bout du compte il
n'aura plus du tout les mêmes
caractéristiques sensible que celle
qu'il avait au départ ça ça prouve pour
des cartes qu'on ne peut pas définir un
objet physique par ses caractéristiques
physiques
on doit les définir par autre chose leur
essence se situe au delà de la matière
et donc dans le cas du morceau de cire
des cartes va dire puisque je ne peux
pas le définir par sa couleur
puisqu'elle change
je ne peux pas le définir par sa forme
puisqu'elle change également
ce par quoi en revanche je peux définir
le morceau de cire c'est par le fait
qu'il a la capa
cité de se transformer c'est presque une
tautologie en fait comme raisonnement
c'est de dire que ceux qui définit
n'importe quel être physique c'est son
caractère d'être physique mais en fait
c'est plus qu'une tautologie pas ce que
ça veut simplement dire qu'on ne peut
pas définir davantage ce qu'est un corps
physique parce que tout ce qu'on
pourrait dire sur lui serait soumis à
l'évolution à la transformation et donc
ne serait pas une vérité absolue une
vérité réel donc là encore chez
descartes comme chez platon il y à
l'idée que les idées les vérités
intelligible son éternel qu'elles sont
en dehors du temps en dehors de l'espace
et que ce qu'on appelle vérité devrait
en réalité de correspondre qu'à ses
formes de vérité c'est-à-dire à des
vérités éternelles
alors évidemment c'est toujours
difficile de parler de vérité éternelle
dans un univers physique puisque
précisément le caractère physique de
notre univers on ne sait pas s'il est de
toute éternité ou pas hein c'est très
difficile de penser ne serait-ce que la
question de l'origine immatériel de
l'origine non physique d'un monde
physique et c'est justement d'ailleurs
la question qui occupe les
métaphysiciens c'est à dire ceux qui
essayent de penser ce qui transcende le
monde physique donc parler de vérité
éternelle est un petit peu compliqué
mais pour des cartes comme pour platon à
l'époque de l'antiquité les idées sont
des réalités des réalités éternelle et
ça d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de le
mettre en comparaison avec ceux qu'on
trouve dans la bible c'est à dire au
commencement était le verbe dans ces
camps grecque
le verbe c'est logos et le logos c'est
l'esprit le logos c'est la pensée c'est
l'intellect
c'est à dire que le logo c'est en
rapport direct avec l'idée le logo c'est
l'esprit le logos c'est le monde des
idées
et dire que au commencement était le
verbe c'est peut-être dire qu'au
commencement étaient les idées au
commencement était l'esprit
donc là encore au risque de me répéter
c'est intéressant de constater que pour
des cartes ce qui va le mieux définir
l'être humain c'est sa dimension
immatérielle c'est sa dimension
spirituelle c'est son esprit parce que
l'esprit
il produit la pensée dont je ne peux
douter contrairement au corps dont je
peux douter
contrairement à la matière la matière
qui se transforme sans cesse je ne peux
pas douter de ce qui est éternelle en
moins je ne peux pas douter de ce qui
précède et qui survit à la matière ce
qui veut dire si on y réfléchit que au
des cartes ce qui nous définit le mieux
c'est notre éternité c'est que nous
sommes des êtres dont la réalité va bien
au delà de notre existence
parce que si les choses de la matière
peuvent exister les choses de l'esprit
peuvent faire plus qui existaient elles
peuvent être est ce qui est n'a pas
forcément besoin d'exister pour être de
la même façon que nous n'avons pas
besoin de sortir de chez nous pour
prouver que nous existons nous savons
que nous existons
le fait d'être n'implique pas
d'extérioriser l'être et ce n'est pas
parce que nous sommes que nous sommes
obligés de faire savoir que nous sommes
on peut se contenter d'être sans se
montrer sans s'extérioriser l'esprit
aurait pu se contenter d'être
il aurait ainsi pu continuer à être à
être de toute éternité
mais il faut croire qu'il a eu besoin de
compagnie ou d'une image d'une image de
soi
peut-être que l'esprit a voulu se
regarder dans un miroir et que c'est
nous
son miroir nous sommes
le miroir de l'esprit ouais et si c'est
le cas
bayer pas jojo